esta es una captura de pantalla de un
ejercicio de khan academy que dice el
número 48 es tantas veces como 68
escribe esta comparación como una
ecuación que utiliza la multiplicación
pausa en el vídeo y tratan de resolver
esto por su cuenta
muy bien suena bastante sofisticado esto
de escribe esta comparación como una
ecuación que utilice la multiplicación
pero en realidad solamente nos piden
escribir esto como una ecuación y si
estuviéramos en el portal de khan
academy escribiríamos la respuesta en
este recuadro pero vamos a hacerlo a
mano ya que esta es una captura de
pantalla nos dicen el número 48 y cuando
dice es podemos interpretarlo como que
es igual a algo que es igual esto es
igual a tantas veces como 68 de qué otra
forma podemos escribir tantas veces como
6-8 pues podemos escribirlo como 6 por 8
esto de aquí es esta comparación escrita
como una ecuación que utiliza la
multiplicación es todo lo que nos piden
es lo que escribiríamos en este recuadro
veamos otro ejemplo aquí nos preguntan
cuál enunciado representa a la ecuación
7 x 4 igual a 28 pausa en el vídeo y
piensen en cuál opción elegiría en
ustedes
veamos la opción dice 28 es 74 esto no
es cierto 28 no es 74 pero si escribimos
esto como una ecuación 28 es es igual a
7 + 4
lo escribimos tal cual 74 esto no sólo
no es verdadero sino que tampoco es
igual a esta ecuación por lo que
descartamos esta opción 28 es tantas
veces como 74 esto es interesante 28 es
igual a tantas veces como 7 47 por 4
bueno la única diferencia entre esto y
esto es que están intercambiados los
lados de la igualdad lo que está bien
así que 28 es igual a 7 por 4 que es la
misma ecuación de 7 por 4 igual
me gusta esta opción veamos las otras
opciones 7 es 4 veces 28 esto puede
sonar enredado vamos a escribirlo como
ecuación 7 es igual a 4 veces 28 que es
4 por 28 primero esto no es verdadero ya
que 4 por 28 es mayor que 100 así que no
es 7 pero además esto es muy diferente a
lo que tenemos aquí arriba por lo que
descartamos esta opción
7 es 4 menos que 28 esto es 28 menos 4
nuevamente esto no solamente no es
verdadero pues 28 menos 4 es 24 17 sino
que tampoco es la ecuación original por
lo que también descartamos esta opción
nos quedamos con la opción b